good morning family and I'm calling you
guys family because we share so much of
our life with you that I feel like you
know more about what's going on in me
GEOS taika and even Mia's life more than
our actual family and today's Vlog is
going to be a little bit different I'm
calling it take family to work day
because we've been sharing a lot of our
vacations house updates like the pool
getting built and all that and I love
sharing all of our our family wins with
y'all but that's a one-sided perspective
of our life and I was like you know what
I should share the work perspective
because I used to share what goes on
with JK barbell all that stuff all the
time and I haven't done so
um anymore because things just got
really really busy so if you guys like
this side of our life and we want to see
more of this hit the like button let me
know in the comments below and uh we'll
share way more of the work side of
things
before we get into the project side of
things let me update you guys on my
office because I don't know if I did an
office tour and bear with me
it's a mess if you guys follow me on
Instagram you'll see I've been bouncing
back and forth from LA to Vegas to
Sacramento back to Vegas to Texas it's
been nuts the last couple of months so I
haven't really been able to settle in
but I do have progress so should we
start with the left side or the right
side let's start with the right side
this looks better
so I set up a little uh barbell Brigade
corner
um just like some of the stuff that I've
been very very proud of that we launched
like our gloves I really like that old
English design those hats some of the
coolest pieces that we've had I remember
this flannel jacket we dropped I think
last year
um the squad collection deadlift tea
singlets
there's just a lot of things that we've
uh produced throughout the years and I
wanted to create like a little barbell
corner so that like I can see what we've
done and how I can continue to inspire
and what direction we should go these
shoes right here actually have a ton of
sentimental value so these bad boys are
my very first power lifting shoe and the
reason why I have it here I actually
need a I have a glass case somewhere
that's supposed to go oh it's underneath
so that you see those glass pieces it
forms a box that goes over so if this
never was
this never was you know so that's why
it's like the origin it's my very first
pair of shoes that I bought when I used
to watch West Side uh Barb videos all
the time and I picked up a pair of
Chucks started training powerlessly in
2012 of my first meeting in 2013 and 10
years later we are here today some of
the supplements we dropped you guys know
I love Hawaii so I got all kinds of
stuff over here
and over here this is one of my favorite
photos of taika that Geo took and the
reason why I chose to blow that one up I
wanted a constant reminder
to always
have childlike wonder and be happy like
life is in here right it's never about
reality it's always about your
perception or reality and when I look at
this picture it makes no sense do you
guys know why he has roller skates on
it's because he was on this Jungle Gym
okay and he wanted to climb the jungle
gym with roller skates makes zero sense
he ends up falling off and I think he
imagined how funny that is and he
started dying laughing
that to me
is such an amazing perspective on life
because that's his reality I'm sure
Geo's reality was like oh my God what
are you doing you're gonna break your
neck roller skates you can't climb
anything with that you know and that's
so like adult cerebral
uh not optimistic and so life is about
how you see it so I always want to
remind myself I want to be in this guy's
brain and of course I love happy stuff
so Ninja Turtles and also the office
doesn't get any cooler than that on this
side on the uh more work end I was
finally able to
get dual monitors and it's actually
technically quad monitors because uh
those are double wide monitors
so you guys might be going wait why do
you have so many computer screens well I
have my laptop that I travel with I have
dual monitors because I do a lot of our
design we'll have to blow up and I look
through a lot of spreadsheets like when
you're a CEO
or if you're any type of upper level
management you're looking at data
reports all the time
so some of the spreadsheets that I have
you open it and there's like 20
different columns you're looking at
different quarters year over year it's a
lot so I don't want to be like looking
like that and then over here is our
special podcast and Vlog computer and I
have a dedicated landline for that so
that I can send footage so it's way
faster because the last thing I want is
upload like 20 gigs of something and it
slows down my real work or not my real
work but my the work that I'm working on
and the rest of it is freaking messy
because we have like random samples that
we're working on for barbell like
working on knee sleeves which I'll show
you guys more later like uh other
hoodies random just like pieces that I
haven't been able to clean up even that
whole thing over there's just a big mess
but I'm able to work so oh and you guys
might see all that those are all the
different colors that uh we make at
bottle Brigade for our t-shirts so I
have that set up there
yeah this is pretty much my work setup
from day to day I try to keep it as
clean and aesthetic as possible which is
why everything's so white like I really
like everything you know white white
table as you guys saw I powder coated
the whole table white like that clean
look reminds me of a blank white canvas
it's very inspiring
um but I also like industrial like let's
get to work so that's kind of like the
whole theme of this place hopefully by
the end of this year I can get all this
put together
one thing that's kind of ironic
like we have a pretty much like a work
operating system slash server
that's quite complicated and
sophisticated that we use for all of our
Barber Brigade stuff and it actually
costs a thousand dollars a month to
operate but all of our projects our
communication imagine a slack if you
guys have heard slack or Monday imagine
those two put together on steroids
that's what we use and the part that's
ironic is as organized as we are on
there my personal daily tasks
I put it on this people know what I'm
doing but I like the old school pen and
paper something that's very like
visceral to me about writing what I need
to do down I don't know if it's my 80d
or whatever but it helps ingrain not
only uh why I need to do it what I need
to do but also the feelings I have
behind it like I can go oh that's really
urgent or oh this is like a funny thing
I could do it later and
um yeah so that's what I have over here
that's like on my work desk here over
here uh not sure when this Vlog is gonna
come out but if it comes out before May
17th
uh here's a secret announcement we're
actually working on a spring sale for
bottle Brigade we're going to drop the
announcement on May 15th but it actually
goes Live May 17th and it's only a 24
hour thing so May 19th last day that's
going to be gone I'm just gonna say this
you're literally seeing what I'm writing
like Banner is going to say 48 Hours
only that's the banner on the website
so here is a look into our operating
software
every single project is on the front
page and it's by date like that's the
517 spring sale I told you guys about
this was the May 3rd Athletics
collection you guys saw my Instagram
this new project the Americana
collection that we're dropping in June I
am extremely excited about
let me move this over here
and end this uh on this page it shows
the date campfire is where we have
discussions with the whole team we have
apparel ambassadors message boards on
marketing marketing assets media files
like our photos videos the whole
conversations amongst the staff like
invoices that need to get paid artwork
all of that stuff you can see all the
activity on here
like I said this is like slack and
Monday on steroids but it keeps us
highly organized because we're working
on multiple projects at once and this is
the line blown up
so we have everything is like Americana
inspired we got a panther we got that
snake rapping through BB we got the
Raven and we're restocking our mesh
shorts because these crushed like they
pretty much sell out like within the
hour almost every single drop so we're
bringing back all the colors and I'm
really excited because all of these look
good together and a sticker pack
and this is some of the issues we have
to deal with like when I got this back
from the graphic design I don't even
know how this happens
it was brabble Brigade like this
Design's so freaking sick right and it
says brabl Brigade
I'm like what the heck is Bravo Brigade
like this happens all the time I
remember in 2015 we were doing uh or
2016 we did the LA fit expo
and we're about to drop 500 beanies
there and when we pulled the beanies out
of the box the tag the label it says
Barrel Brigade
Barrel not barbell Barrel Brigade
of course we're pissed and we spent a
lot of money but to fix all those things
and hiccups are never fun but that I
understand because
um they're in China at least those tags
were so maybe they don't understand
English this graphic designer is from
America okay and I'm like how do you
how can you be this sick of an artist
and mess these things up anyways we got
it fixed so don't worry if you grab one
of these t-shirts it's gonna say barbell
Brigade
um it's not gonna say
bear uh what do those say Bravo Brigade
so I'm really excited about this line
see see that background
It's pretty dope right so this here
is our knee sleeve in development and
I'm really excited about this because
we're trying to come out with one of the
strongest knee sleeves on the market
let's see if you can see it over here
all right you see that
look how stiff this is
so we're trying to get it where if you
wear these
you can immediately at like 20 pounds to
your squat so that your Squat and your
knees feel that much more stable so
we've uh agreed and finalized the
material like it's very very strong
and now we just need to work on the
designs which thank you guys so much for
helping out because I did conduct a poll
and
on the pole
over a thousand of you guys voted
because I was kind of like split on the
fence like I want to make sure what I
find dope is dope for you guys too but
sometimes like we don't see eye to eye
or whatever so of course your guys's
opinion is way more important than mine
but all of you guys voted and over 60
percent wanted this one so that's the
one that we're going to get the
production sample for it's sublimated
meaning like there's a pattern in the
back that's built into the material and
it's the BBS everywhere and then we got
the hardcore skulls in the front which
is what this
will end up looking like
and we also wanted to make sure that we
up ourselves a notch to our competitors
so a lot of like
the the same items will get made at the
same manufacturer like that's just how
manufacturing works like a factory might
produce Ford cars and Chevy or Toyota
you know like that
so the manufacturer sent us this
um drawstring bag to put the knee
sleeves in which I do like the mesh so
it helps it breathe because if you guys
have knee sleeves it gets sweaty and
stuff and then the branding's at the
bottom I'd never like double branding
like that that's like a big graphic
design no no
but the problem with that one is
one of our friends that also just
dropped knee sleeves recently that bag
looks way too similar right it's like
the mesh you got the sleeves and so I
was like no no no no I want it
to look different so the design that we
came up with is this one first of all
matches the knee sleeve it's the
sublimated material it's clear that it's
bottled Brigade on the outside for this
one I didn't mind not having a bottle
Brigade because I always figure knee
sleeves are more of like a sport
competition thing
I like it and I like it when it looks
clean you know like that's one of my
favorite things about Nike like it just
looks clean it's like I'm here to talk
with my actions and that's it so I
didn't want to like over brand it or
anything but with this one we got to
make sure who we are so we put barbell
and then this whole front side is solid
and then the back side is mesh
so then that way the entire backside
breathes and I also wanted to make a bag
where if you guys don't want to put knee
sleeves in it like for me for example I
have my own mesh bag so I don't need to
put my knee sleeves in that bag now I
can use that for shoes or other stinky
things that need to breathe and I think
it's a way better design than something
like this or even our competitors like
this they're not the only brand but a
lot of them only have a cinch top I want
it to be like a wearable backpack so
that's where we are with this
this project is a little bit further
along I believe this one's dropping in
September the Americana collection you
guys just saw that one's dropping in
June so if we excited about that one
stay tuned for that one
so both of those are apparel based
projects that we're working on we call
it Labs internally because that's where
we like create stuff
on the gym and his bottle Brigade is Gem
supplements apparel and digital training
programs we're having our very first
drug tested usaple meet in July as well
so for those a lot of gyms like to do
like a meaty kind of like the uh
memorabilia piece or something that like
you know when you do a Spartan Race or
Marathon you get to buy a T-shirt and I
was like how can we do it different
because I feel like a lot of them look
the same and they kind of have this
souvenir feel it doesn't look like like
oh I want to just want to rock this
regularly so I was like you know what I
like I like like tour date posters let's
put that on a tea and then also whoever
signed up
instead of the tour dates and the
locations let's put the names on there
so now people get to have a wearable
yearbook so that is our meaty for this
year which I think is crazy sick we have
I set this up so it almost looks like
hieroglyphics you know like USA po
Barber Brigade 2023 open power lifting
me so through symbols we tell the story
and everyone that signed up in session
one session two all your names will be
on there
July 22nd I know we filled up like crazy
fast
um the minute we launched it then we
filled up within the first couple hours
so if you guys want this tea you guys
couldn't get in on it I think we're
gonna try to do another one in November
so stay tuned for that but
um this is something I'm extremely
excited about
so to prep for the power lifting meat
we're making sure our gym is like ready
and presentable and so one of the first
layers we did is change all the light
bulbs because some of them are starting
to dim change colors so not only did we
change all the light bulbs in the gym
um we also installed some extra ones so
some of the darker areas in the gym is
extremely bright as you can see like
this whole genetics even the front is
extremely well lit so obviously I'm not
in LA but we have an amazing amazing
manager Brian and I communicate with him
through base camp so he gives us like
updates like right here just to let us
know the progress of everything
so here's a project that's a little bit
more Rough Around the Edges not Rough
Around the Edges still more in
development I should say it's like in a
rougher draft
so this is our best-selling mesh short
um every time we drop like I told you
guys it sells out like within the hour
and we already have those five colors
but we feel like there's a bunch more
colors that people would want that would
also look freaking sick
so I was really excited to kind of
almost come out with a not pastel but
almost like a slate
slate line like you know like slate blue
looks way different than blue and I feel
like there's like a slave version of
every color slate green slate black or
whatever
so these are the next three colors I'm
trying to develop so if you can imagine
this short in like a slate blue or like
a slate or they call it rifle green but
like a slate green or even a cool gray I
think will look pretty sick
um what they do is we let them know the
Pantone the Pantone is like the official
like coloring guide for the universe
that's how like a graphic designers
painters everyone can be on the same
page as to what the color code is and
they just send us back swatches to see
how close it is and then from this I go
oh like add more blues or like add more
grays and these are the swatches
they come back and this is a smart way
to communicate because then this is way
cheaper right to just dye the fabric
than to create a whole new short so
that's how everything is then it's done
in like phases where they send a Swatch
and then we check the colors if it's
good then they'll make a prototype if
the Prototype is good then we Mass
produce and make hundreds or thousands
of them so this is their blue they're
green obviously this green is way
lighter so I want a darker version of
this this one um this one's actually not
bad it's actually a nice color it is
different from here so I'm asking from a
different variation and then I'll choose
between the two which one I like the
most and I'm asking for a pretty like
custom gray like this gray is Almost
White so they sent this which to me
looks like straight up white so I think
for them they're like maybe the printer
can't even get there because the Pantone
can also change depending on the medium
like whether it's cotton silk plastic
whatever so they sent this one this is
their available gray color and that's
actually a really nice gray too looking
at that like imagine having like three
shorts dropped in these these three it
would actually look pretty good so
that's uh mesh shorts that we will be
releasing in maybe July or August around
that time frame so yeah we're always
trying to work like a quarter ahead
quarter meaning like a couple months
so that we can uh keep the projects
flowing
back to that May 17th sale I was telling
you guys about so we have some select
apparel that will
um be discounted most of our apparels
sold out like the minute or like the
week that we launched so we don't have
much left there but we do have 25 off
all of our supplements so this is a
really good time to stock up because
it's our first sale of the year and we
probably won't have another sale all the
way until probably Black Friday but some
of the things that you can get in the
sale is 25 off is everything that I take
daily so protein obviously super
important if you're trying to lose
weight build muscle build strength
anything like that it's really important
our protein is triple filtered which
means there's zero fat zero carbs
lactose free so if you're lactose you
don't have to worry about that and we
have 25 grams of protein per serving so
it's a very very high quality protein
not to mention the flavor is delicious
horchata we got our pre-workout which is
what I take to get amped and hype for a
workout and focus because we got feet in
the entire scene 350 milligrams of
caffeine one thing that really separates
us from the market we also have three uh
different species of adaptogenic
mushrooms which is known to fight stress
oxidative stress help you stay focused
so I believe we have the strongest
pre-workout on the market and it's the
cleanest like most people that take it
to me they don't have a crash
um so they love this I take this with
our strength stack
if you guys are in strength training
trying to build muscle you guys know how
important creatine is to start creatine
and glycerol blend so creatine helps you
build muscle get stronger train harder
and then glycerol uh gives you an insane
pump the flavors of course are always
delicious we got Jamaica punch and sour
gummy greens this is like your daily
insurance it's hard for a lot of people
to eat a ton of veggies so you can get
six superfood veggies in one little
scoop tastes delicious papino
and then our immunity support which is
our electrolyte blend stay hydrated be
complex vitamin C a thousand milligrams
and what separates us from a lot of the
other electrolyte Blends is our
electrolytes are from organic sources so
freeze-dried coconut Himalayan sea salt
not just a lot of companies which is
straight up
get this you know
straight up like Morton salt and just
dump it in because it's cheaper for us
at bottled organ Boutique brand so we
try to use the highest quality
ingredients which means there's also
more bile available bioavailable meaning
uh more ready for your body to be
absorbed like if you've ever taken like
a cheap multivitamin
you go at night and then you pee like
straight up golden yellow because your
body's not absorbing any of it not to
mention we also do have a multivitamin
that takes care of bone gut heart and uh
overall health so your bones your hair
all that and ours you will not pee
yellow because we use as you just can
see like some of the highest quality
ingredients that's where they have their
own specific logos
back there so a multivitamin all of
these bad boys
are 25 off May 17th and now it's time to
walk Mia because that's also my midday
work Break
um also get get my steps in
and also me has been such a good dog
that she deserves
quinoa
and guess who's back the young lady
what happened
um
oh he just spread his little freaking
germy germs on me and I he's been sick
yeah but hasn't been complaining of any
type of discomfort other than just being
all flemmy and like a slight cough yeah
his cough is gone now but last night
like at maybe 11 or 12 I woke up because
my throat was so dry and Scratchy and it
was so raw that feeling it was just so
painful
um you feel better now yeah I went to
the I went to Urgent Care and um they
prescribed like four different
medications I'm like bro this is
excessive but it's not ready yet so I'd
rather just get some work in and then
I'll go pick it up around lunch or
something
I don't feel worse
but the more it goes untreated I
probably will get worse yeah I'm glad
you caught it early though
it's so painful
painful
that's one of the tough things too like
when you own your own business and you
got kids
and you're doing both you can't afford
to get sick because then it's like
losing a team member like we need all
hands on deck like both me and Geo
included like when I feel sick I
actually feel guilty I get up
someone doesn't feel guilty at all
what in the human lazy bum
glitter pop
before I take Mia for a walk
I realized I had to make lunch
so I got carried away I had to bang out
some more computer stuff
um and I'm like oh [__] it's lunch time
and when you're trying to hit your
protein requirements like for me I'm
trying to hit about 200 grams of protein
because that's the process of losing
weight because you don't want to get
from like fat fat to skinny fat and how
do you do that you want to increase your
protein so as you lose weight you
maintain the muscle while you lose the
fat so
um I need to make sure I portion out all
my food or else it's almost impossible
to eat like
200 grams of protein in one sitting so
today I'm going to be making some
boneless skinless chicken thighs I love
things that are three to one or four to
one protein ratio this one is almost
five to one so uh 4.5 grams of fat 22
grams of protein so that's almost like a
five to one protein the fat ratio I'll
be making this with lemon pepper
um oh and I love stir fry
veggies because it makes it easy so I
always just buy it
like this because you know when you're
busy you want things convenient and done
for you and I try to get a mixture of
veggies so that there's like a good
variety of like nutrition and vitamins
so I got some mushrooms asparagus onions
probably cook that
um tossing in some garlic salt and just
sprinkle some ponzu just like something
really light and then make a white
rice
this is one of my favorite things about
having a dog you can cut off the fatty
piece they're going to throw away
anyways but just give it to them and
they love it yummy
so when I'm cooking to be on a diet
especially midweek I just want fast
efficient I need to eat and go back to
work so this is really simple little
garlic salt
lemon pepper mix it all up
and ready to throw it on a pan
I got the chicken on the pan
and just to give the veggies a slightly
different profile like flavor profile I
use slap your mama Cajun seasoning it's
just a little bit of a kick and just
tastes slightly different from the
chicken so then that way when you're
eating stuff you know like throughout
the week I like to make a lot like this
will probably last probably like three
or four meals
um that way you don't get sick of it
because then you kind of have like a
good thing to bounce back and forth from
could I have some lemons which I do oh
man I don't know how dry this is but
I'll probably put a splash of lemon in
the veggies to make it taste a little
bit brighter
and the chicken's looking good
lemon is something you want to add at
the end I found out the hard way when I
was first started learning how to cook
because there's sugars in lemon so it'll
straight up start
um crystallizing and then burning
because of the sugar content so it's
something you want to add on the end
because it can make your food bitter if
you add too early and sometimes like you
put on something and the lemon flavor
just evaporates because you put too
early too so I found out that the lemon
does have some juice which is pretty
good so I chopped it up already and
another thing that's really important
is that when you're busy when you're
waiting for the food to cook instead of
being on your phone and wasting time
this is a good time to do any other
chore in the kitchen so for me that's
putting all my dirty dishes in the
dishwasher and also taking all the clean
dishes and putting it away so a lot of
the times and trust me I've been there
to feel it feels like you don't have
enough time like how do you have enough
time to like work out train wash the
dishes do the dishes cook your food and
still run so many businesses
it's how can you be more efficient with
your time is the real question to ask
because there's people that are even
busier than me
that can do all of the above so most of
the time it's in one hour are you just
stuck in the one thing and in the phone
for the rest or are you doing like six
to ten things per hour
so that's what I'm saying right now
putting all this stuff away
and then by the time the food is done
guess what the dishes are also ready to
be washed
all right so the chicken's done
it's really good added a splash of lemon
got the veggies done
so all I need to do is wait for the rice
cooker still says about 20 minutes
um this thing is a liar
sometimes they'll go like 20 and then
out of nowhere it goes to like eight and
based on the amount of rice I put in
there I think it's gonna lie to me today
so it says 20 but I'm thinking it's
probably going to be like less than 10
so it's gonna be perfect enough time to
clear all of this
did I just say this I don't know why I
say it like that and then put that into
the dishwasher
see bam cleared the sink and you might
be wondering wait so if you got the
dishwasher loaded how come you didn't
put it in yet and it's all about
preparation and efficiency because I
know once I serve this food guess what I
got two more dirty pans so what I'm
gonna do is when I serve the food I'll
package these guys in the tupperwares
and I'll throw those last two in there
that way we do one quick efficient wash
and uh it's about getting pretty close
time to have lunch
[Music]
all right threw the pans in there
because I put the leftovers and the
tupperware's already
Mama Bear's not feeling good so I feel
very very bad but I know mama likes
asparagus that's why I cook asparagus
for her
that's very nice
excuse me can you do the taste test tell
me how tastes yeah
I'm trying to eat the rice crust oh my
God
because I have some of yours in Texas
jeans after all
perfectly cheesy
season very good big candy very good I
love it thank you I'm a big fat so I've
been eating like crap so
I'm doing no rice only just chicken and
veggies yeah she's waiting for anything
to fall around
just finished yummy lunch now it's time
to take Mia on a walk
and uh since I didn't train today I
don't have too many steps in so I gotta
make up a lot a lot of it
so I will be walking for probably almost
an hour to get like six to seven
thousand steps in and usually during
this time
um I like to be efficient and listen to
like real estate or Finance or business
podcasts too
um and that's how I'm able to kind of
keep increasing my knowledge in
education well
uh bump it up my fitness but I hope you
guys liked
um the bring family to work day Vlog I'm
gonna end it right here because when I'm
walking with me I can't be bringing a
camera with me
um let me know if you like this I'll do
more of these share more about projects
but if any of these projects interests
you the main ones to keep track of is
May 17th we're having our first sale of
the year the spring sale 25 off select
apparel and supplements and then also in
June we have the super sick Americana
collection the one with the snake that
we saw
and uh in July we have our powerlifting
meet if you guys want to come
um and watch and support
and
um the knee sleeves that's coming way
later on but I'll keep updating you guys
and I'll update you guys with my office
as I hopefully get a chance to clean up
this big old mess
[Music]